the last time we spoke
the whole band was single
yeah what's the status today the whole
band story
yeah richard i just want to ask you a
question about your beautiful daughter
aaliyah because of her i feel inspired
to live a long life and provide when i
heard la noche and i started going
through the lyrics i was like i need a
second i was like this is really hot
i expect a lot of that expect a lot and
more of that you know
hi cnco
it's so good to see you guys how's
everything going amazing we're grateful
and happy right now yeah well i see
these big smiles i have to believe that
it's because
you're in the middle of something
magical a new era the last time i saw
you on the set of me necesita
it was pre-pandemic
and there were five of you
now there's four of you so tell me about
this transition how has it been well
it's been it's been interesting to be
honest you know i think this transition
helped us to find different
areas that we didn't really experiment
on musically musical wise
um and also like you know it gave us
time to reflect and kind of just like
see oh where do we want to go how do we
want to look what do we want to give our
fans you know or what what are they
asking for at the end of the day you
know you're listening um yeah so we kind
of just listened we kind of just looked
at all the the the comments and
everything that that fans always put
um and you know they're growing with us
so what's better than giving them a an
authentic and more of a mature version
of cnco with growing and evolving now as
a quartet four of you i mean eric tell
me what has the biggest challenge been
uh recalibrating as a foursome i think
it's just that i'm renewing and like
trying to find the new sound um of the
new music um and the noche is used like
a little
um
yes ningpic of
all the um the songs that we are working
on zombie tell me what has it been like
for you being part of a quartet now it's
been like a cool like process honestly
that we're super proud and we're like
super like
um ready excited to go you guys hear
everything we have ready for you guys
chris i want to ask you because i feel
like you've talked a lot about
cnco it's not just a band it's a
brotherhood you guys truly have a
connection that is unspeakable and for
your buddy joelle he's going on a new
journey you guys are going on a new
journey what is your relationship with
him like today i mean
he's her brother he will never stop
being a brother
right now he just took a different path
and we support him 100
but you know everybody who have those
you know those
those moments and like that it's just
you just got you just need to be
supported you know
and that's what we did with him
foundation's still here with cnco you
know and and we just want to continue
making legacy with with ha you know as
much as we can you know yeah and we just
support it with him and we just continue
like the best area of cincio is about to
come i think so now that you are a
foursome i am curious were there ever
conversations about changing the band
name i've seen some fans on twitter
saying qtro you're going to be quite
thrown out
did you ever did you ever consider that
no no no no no not really yeah
cnco is so dope you know so why change
something that you know we fell in love
with from the beginning i actually
matches because cnco is for support
right c and ceo perfect
it's kind of cool too i'm hoping that
you can offer a message to your fans you
know i think a few people are concerned
that once someone goes on a new journey
maybe others are going to follow what is
your message to fans who are you know
thinking about the future of cnco and
what it will look like i mean
that we're working crazy we're more
concentrated than ever we have
the power and the will to do whatever
right now we want with our careers okay
so confirmed right here cnco not going
anywhere no no no no
yes nowhere but up love it
all the way up all the way up listen you
took us all the way up with the release
of your new single toe
[Music]
just sort of like a uh like a kind of
like an introduction yeah it's just
coming you know step one yeah because
because the thing about cnco that we've
always had too i think that's never
changed is that we've always liked to
swim in different waters you know we
like to you know do different languages
you know do a
feature way with a boy band you know
then uh italian you know artist and uh
you know brazilian so we always like to
try new things so i think the the
this is kind of an introduction lyrical
wise you know because it's a little bit
more grown more mature it's a little bit
more sensual hey
we gotta talk about that when i heard la
noche and i started going through the
lyrics i was like
i was like i need a second i was like
this is really hot
i expect a lot of that expect a lot and
more of that
[Music]
eric what is the biggest accomplishment
that you want to achieve with this new
era of cnco one of them i think is just
um
do something
um
apart from music and be more like in the
art of like movies do movies do like
series do stuff like that um we're
working on some stuff that we still can
like cannot say nothing about it but i'm
sorry a cnco movie
um
that's huge
yeah
the fans will go crazy
so we're working on some
around there you know we can't really
say nothing specifically yeah cnc movie
but we just can't we have to say that
it's something that we always have yeah
like wanted to do one and then like
can i take a wild guess tour documentary
some sort of a documentary about life on
the road or life in the band you're
smiling
if if this was to happen when could we
expect it
that's
okay well listen i i hope also coming
soon a new album
yes no album yes
confirmed okay he is not confirmed for
this year or exactly we don't know this
year or next year
okay cool and
more sensual than ever before yeah yeah
for sure yeah that's for sure tell me
what that means where are you getting
this inspiration from
is that is that we like how like our
fancies are like growing up with us i
think it's the moment at the perfect
moment to like just like giving her like
um those type of lyrics you know it's
not like it's super heavy but it's a
little more like spicy yeah do you think
like
it's a little spicy like then our songs
are like more like
heavy and just like using them so we we
should prepare ourselves we should
prepare ourselves
you're about to hit the road club tour
what can fans who have been waiting so
patiently for years to see you live what
can they expect from this experience
don't come in heels if you want to come
in here it's great but you know just
know that you're going to party you're
going party party you know we're gonna
drink we're gonna just have a good time
at the end of the day i think this is
more to like celebrate the the new era
you know
and kind of just bring it with the best
spirit that we can and you know and kind
of start the motor with with a great uh
stomp on the on the ground you know and
a great energy at the end of the day and
we're here at your rehearsals behind the
scenes how have things been going
exciting it's exciting
we can wait for four people for people
here everything we have ready and also
like
for being touring with people and party
it will be fun i think the last time we
spoke
the whole band was single still singing
you know waiting for that girl to to
find us or for us to find each other you
know what's the status today the whole
band studies
yeah ready to mingle what do you what do
you look for how do you go about dating
when you've got such a high public
profile it is hard you know like right
now sometimes you just don't have
a
private life kind of um
but
i mean we just go out from
partying around you know but we don't
date date like that i i haven't dated in
a while like day-date properly dating in
a while and if it does happen it doesn't
really last long yeah you know because
of communications and stuff like that
you know distance yeah
but we're still having fun
so for inquiring minds for everybody out
there watching this what does catch your
eye in a potential partner
what what qualities i love confidence
smile charismatic big smile very
much
celebrity crushes you know what recently
i've been watching a little bella porch
uh
unbelievable like the music that she
came with it's really good and she's
beautiful too so okay bella porch yeah
are you a potterhead harry potter fan
yes
richard who catches your eye
i'm gonna be honest i really am gonna be
honest i don't have a crush right now
okay you're married to the music
yeah and i you know i like i like a lot
of pretty girls so it's like not
like like oh this one drives me crazy
recently i've been looking a lot too
i think it's really pretty um oh yeah
and um marisol
oh yeah she's such an amazing singer too
yes i mean bella porch madison beer
there's so many people that i would
personally love to see you collaborate
with we have a playlist we have a fake
list take me through it um
we can say that yankee that is for sure
on the top but like daddy drinks
brow would be amazing sage
yeah
[Music]
richard i just want to ask you a
question about your beautiful daughter
aaliyah when we see pictures on
instagram
my heart skips a beat just like seeing
you as such an incredible father to your
little one how does she inspire your
work as an artist
um
i think in a lot of ways you know
because right now like let's say before
when you don't have a a daughter or
anybody to take care of uh i feel like
you really focus on yourself a lot you
know but now you have a different entity
to take care of you you know it's like
another part of you you know so now you
have to take care of two persons that is
you
you know and that
fills my heart with
with uh energy to just keep working and
keep pushing you know because at the end
of the day like if she's not well then
i'm not gonna be well if i'm not well
then she won't be well i'm just very
inspired and very you know active you
know because of her because of her i
feel inspired to live a long life and
provide you know that's so beautiful and
you are an amazing father i'm curious
guys spending time with little aliyah
what is that like and does it give you a
little bit of baby fever of course yeah
of course
she's beautiful she's beautiful she's
something i think she likes more
something
always had a crush on saudi
when he was blunt it was more right yeah
sabine and eric you know sometimes she
she mentions eric because of the eyes
yeah of course yeah
the girl's got good taste she's like
chris is like the fun uncle you know
he's like the
the like more hyped
three words to describe the club tour
the cnco club tour
three words
authentic
exciting exciting and
legendary
[Music]